Hi.
I'm Phil Quitslund.
And I'm an engineer on Dart
Editor, our lightweight and
powerful editor for Dart.
In this video I'll give you a
tour of Dart Editor and its
many features to help developers
be more productive
for writing larger,
full-featured web apps.
Dart Editor helps you write web
apps with Dart, the new
scalable web programming
language.
The editor and language are part
of the open-source Dart
project, which also includes
libraries, a new virtual
machine, a package manager,
and more.
Dart compiles to JavaScript to
run across the modern web.
Let's see how to use
Dart Editor now.
When you first start the Dart
Editor, you're greeted by the
Welcome screen.
From here, you can create a
new application, read more
about Dart, or run one
of many samples.
For example, let's see what
this Solar app does.
It simulates the planets
orbiting around the sun.
Neat.
Dart Editor isn't a
stock of clips.
It's a completely standalone
editor optimized for Dart.
You'll quickly see that Dart
Editor has clean menus in a
significantly simplified UI.
Even though things look more
simple, we still have powerful
features, such as auto-update
and configurable key bindings.
If you already use Eclipse,
IntelliJ, or
WebStorm, you're in luck.
These IDs also have Dart
plug-ins available.
Dart Editor can help you learn
Dart with code navigation,
code completion, and more.
Let's see these features
in action.
Here we are looking at
some new Dart code.
I'm curious about this method
here, and I wonder how it's
implemented.
I can simply right-click on it
and choose Open Declaration.
Dart Editor jumps me directly
to the methods definition.
Dart Editor indexes all the
names in your project, making
it easier to find code.
Once you find the code, you can
also easily find out where
else it's used.
For example, I'm not sure
who uses this code.
I can right-click on
the method name
and choose Find Callers.
The Editor finds all the code
that uses the method so you
know where and how it's used.
You can use this functionality
to help clean up your code.
For example, it looks like
no-one else is using this
particular method.
So I can delete it.
Dart Editor also makes it easy
to find a name if you know
what it is.
You can search across the
project for classes, methods,
variable names, and more.
For example, the other day my
buddy told me about some
reconnect logic she wrote.
I searched for reconnect.
And, sure enough, Dart Editor
finds a method called
scheduleReconnect.
Along with navigating the code,
Dart Editor also makes
it easy to explore new APIs.
Because Dart is structured and
has optional static types, the
Editor can provide useful
code completion.
Here I am working with an object
that I'm not familiar
with, and I'm not sure what
methods I can call.
Dart Editor knows what type the
object is and can provide
me with a list of options
specific to this variable.
Even if you don't use type
annotations, the Editor can
often infer types, and code
completion still works.
In this example I used var for
my simple variable that holds
an integer.
Notice how the Editor still
gives me useful code
completion proposals.
Dart Editor can help you fix a
simple problem with a quick
keyboard shortcut.
For example, the Editor can
apply various quick fixes for
missing methods or
missing classes.
Here I've written some code that
uses a method that is not
yet defined.
I clearly got ahead of myself,
but we can fix it.
Simply use Control-1 to bring
up the Quick Fix menu, and
you'll see a Create Method
option complete with
parameters and types.
Once the method is created,
the error goes away.
Other quick fixes include
Create Class, Import
Library, and more.
Writing code is easy, but
maintaining it as requirements
change can be challenging.
Dart Editor has built-in
refactoring support to help
you update the code as
the design evolves.
The name I originally
picked for this
method can be more clear.
I want to rename it, but I
also want to rename all
references across the project.
Right-click on the method
and choose Rename
from the Context menu.
After I choose a new
name, it's changed
all over the project.
Repeating the same
code isn't ideal.
So if you notice the same code
used more than once, you can
apply the Extract Method
refactoring.
Here's code I've repeated
twice in the same file.
It's a great candidate
for extract method.
Highlight the code, right-click,
choose Extract
Method, and choose a name
for the new method.
Notice how the original code is
replaced by a call to the
new method.
Quick fixes and refactorings are
helpful features to keep
you more productive.
But what if you run into
a bug in your code?
Dart Editor has a rich Debugger
to help you find and
fix bugs quickly.
The Debugger connects to
Dartium, our build of
Chromium, with an embedded
Dart VM.
You can set breakpoints,
step your code, inspect
variables, and more.
Here's a sample Dart app,
which clearly has a bug.
We can use the Debugger
to find the error.
I start by checking if
this is a problem
with drawing the planet.
I set a breakpoint inside
the drawSelf method of
PlanetaryBody.
The program stops when the
breakpoint is hit.
Since the positions are wrong,
I'm curious about the point
values of x and y.
Using the Debugger, I can
inspect variable values and
set watched expressions.
I'm looking for anything
out of the ordinary.
Here, I'm comparing x and
y with the previous
frames x and y.
They're reversed.
Sure enough, the bug
is in the code.
It's a simple fix, and
I rerun the program.
It works.
You can avoid adding Debug.Print
statements to all
of your code by using the
Editor's built-in Debugger and
tight integration
with Dart VM.
Dart Editor is open-source, and
we like to hear from our
developers.
If you ever have an idea for a
feature or run into a problem,
click the Send Feedback
button.
Simply tell us what you're
trying to do, click Send, and
the Editor team will
receive your note.
We just scratched the surface
of Dart Editor.
We look forward to hearing
your feedback.
Please download it today
and give it a try.